welcome back to CBS this morning in our
morning rounds how a routine doctor's
visit for a sore throat brought more
than 28,000 dollars in charges this is
an absurd are continuing bill of the
month partnership with Kaiser health
news and NPR looks at unexpected medical
costs that woman's visit shows even when
insurance does cover medical costs costs
can still skyrocket in the long run take
a look I thought maybe because my throat
had started hurting a lot I potentially
had strep throat Alexa Caston wanted to
be sure that her cold symptoms weren't
anything serious so she made an
appointment with a doctor that she had
seen before dr. Roya fought Elahi she
said okay I'll give you a strep throat
culture she sent in a nurse and they did
blood work that was it she gave me a
prescription for antibiotics I left
within 10 days Kasten felt better but
she started to get unexpected messages
from the doctor's office while both the
doctor in the lab that performed the
blood tests were in cast ins Insurance
Network the lab that processed the
throat swab was not Caston was surprised
to learn that the doctor had ordered an
extensive and expensive array of
respiratory tests she didn't give me any
indication that she was gonna do
anything more than just a basic strep
test the bill for those throat swab
tests totaled more than $28,000 after
deducting a copay the insurance company
paid the claim sending Caston a check
for 25,000 $65 she says the doctor's
office which by the way shares a phone
number and an address with that lab
wanted her to turn over the entire
insurance payment immediately Blue Cross
Blue Shield also kind of dropped the
ball here and they you know should have
flagged this and they didn't miss Caston
did give that check to her doctor who
did not respond to our request for
comment Blue Cross Blue Shield of
Minnesota told kaiser Health News it is
now reviewing the claim and his place to
hold on that check for more than $25,000
dr. Elizabeth Rosenthal is editor in
chief of kaiser health
News and she joins us at the table this
morning good morning thanks so much to
unpack here all right yeah so in this
case she wasn't asked to pay the $25,000
right
no she wasn't put in New York State
there's a surprise billing law which
they says which holds patient harmless
but in many states only 12 states have
those laws so in many states they could
have come after her and remember even if
she didn't have to pay it her insurer
did which means everyone in her company
is paying those crazy bills so don't
just say it's not me I don't care dr.
Rosenthal how likely is this to happen
to the average person well there look
this is a very common thing this time of
year probably hundreds of thousands of
New Yorkers are going in with the head
colds getting throat swabs and you just
never know right so it's a little thing
we have these kinds of bills from throat
swabs 20 you know 28,000 we have a urine
test for 18,000 a tube of blood for
8,000 so when the doctor says let's just
swab your throat or let's just you know
give me some urine in a cup you have to
have your antenna up because you just
never know and that's why I always tell
people one thing you can do right away
is when the doctor says something like
that you say okay but send it in my
network for testing so you're safe and
be asked like why are you sending this
test
I mean sure throat swab is normal right
but this throat swab was sent for every
virus and bacteria and DNA testing under
the Sun and that's why it added up
partly why it ended up to be such a
crazy crazy amount and if someone was in
an intensive care unit and dying you
might say all these tests are necessary
if you have a head cold boy right so you
mentioned that lab that did all those
tests there is a connection between the
lab and the doctor what do we know about
that well all we know is that there at
the same address so it's very hard to
know what to make of that you know it it
looks odd right but it could be far away
too it could be 11 I don't know what to
make of that at this point it could be a
lab in Utah but the point is the doctor
sends a minor test to lab the lab can do
can
work up whatever they want the mark-up
can be crazy another lab told us those
same tests might cost $600 20 seconds
how does something like this get passed
on to other patients right so if she too
paid it and not raised a flag how does
this get passed on to the rest of us
well because what insurers do when they
pay out these crazy claims is next year
they just raise premiums on all the rest
of us and so you know it feels like no
one's paying but in fact we're all
paying and plus it's wrong we have a
health system that's totally out of
control in terms of costs and we all
when we see something like this we can't
just say oh I don't have to pay we say
now that's crazy as as Miss Kasdan did
thank goodness right well dr. Rosenthal
thank you for those tips take away pay
attention to those bills
you